SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA.
ATKINS BATES L. FORGES BRADFORD
CABALLERO CHAIN DALLY DODD TO
ROSS SO GALGIANI GLAZER
GONZALEZ THROWS HERTZBERG HILL
HUESO- TADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MITCHELL MONNING MORE
LOCK MORALE NIELSEN PAN
PORTANTINO ROTH RUBIO SKINNER
STERN NUMBER WHY CAO SKI WIENER
WILK. THANK YOU MISTER
SECRETARY A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WE WELCOME YOU BACK ON THIS
ELECTION WEEK HERE IN THE
GOLDEN STATE WITH THE MEMBERS
IN OUR GAS BEYOND THE RAIL IN
THE GALLERY PLEASE RISE WE'RE
GONNA BE LEADING PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR GUEST CHAPLAIN
WE ARE GRATEFUL THAT SISTER
LATELY BE FERNANDES IS BACK
WITH THIS FOUNDER OF MERCY
PEDDLERS AFTER WITCHING ASK
THAT EACH OF YOU REMAIN
STANDING WE'RE GONNA BE LED IN
THE PLEDGE OF LLEGIANCE BY
SENATOR DR SO. LET US PRAY. ALL
KNOWING AND ALL POWERFUL GOD.
WE REMEMBER THAT MARCH IS
WOMEN'S HISTORY MONTH. THANK
YOU FOR ALL OF THE CHERISHED
WOMEN IN OUR LIVES AND IN OUR
HISTORIES. MOTHERS SISTERS
FRIENDS NEIGHBORS AND COWORKERS.
LET US REMEMBER AND REFLECT ON
THE HERITAGE AND THE STRUGGLES
OF WOMEN THROUGHOUT THE AGES.
MAY WE SEE MEN AND WOMEN SEEK
TO LEARN FROM ALL THOSE VOICES
AND ACTIONS OF THE PAST BY
CRAFTING NEW WAYS OF INCLUSION
ANY QUALITY. MAY THIS MONTH OF
REFLECTION TEACHERS TO SEARCH
FOR THOSE STORIES THERE ARE
DIFFERENT FROM OUR OWN FROM OUR
OWN. AND MAY WE BRING OUT THE
VOICES SUCH AS- MAY JENNISON.
THE FIRST AFRICAN AMERICAN
ASTRONAUT. WITH HER WORDS.
NEVER LIMIT YOURSELF BECAUSE OF
OTHERS LIMITED IMAGINATION.
NEVER LIMIT OTHERS BECAUSE OF
YOUR OWN LIMITED IMAGINATION.
AMEN. LEAGUES JOIN
PLEDGE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO
THE FLAG. OF THE UNITED STATES
OF AMERICA. AND TO THE REPUBLIC
FOR WHICH IT STANDS ONE NATION
UNDER GOD. INDIVISIBLE WITH
LIBERTY AND JUSTICE FOR ALL.
THANK YOU. SENATORS THAT WE
IT'S A PRIVILEGE TO BE ABLE TO
HAVE A FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE
SENATE HERE FORMER TREASURER
THE CITY CALIFORNIA AND
ATTORNEY GENERAL CAN WE PLEASE
GIVE A WARM SENATE WELCOME TO
SENATOR BILL LOCKYER. THIS
APPROACH AND WE WELCOME YOU
BACK TO THE CHAMBERS. LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE.
SENATOR MINING HAS A VERY
SPECIAL PRESENTATION. HIS BRIDE
TWENTY STUDENTS TO BE HONORED
HERE TODAY. WE'RE GONNA ASK
THAT THE STUDENTS COME ON FOR
HERE TO THE STEPS WE GET HALF
OF THE SERGEANTS HELP GUIDE THE
STUDENTS FORWARD. MY COME IN
AND GO. BACK AREA. CENTER MONEY
IN IN SCHOOL COLOR TIGHT TODAY
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT MEMBERS
PASSING YOU PLEASE JOIN ME
TODAY AND WELCOMING TO THE
SENATE CHAMBER AN IMPRESSIVE
GROUP OF STUDENTS FROM MY
DISTRICT WE'RE ALL STUDYING AT
CAL POLY STATE UNIVERSITY IN
SAN LUIS OBISPO THIS DELEGATION
INCLUDE SOME OF CAL POLY'S MOST
EXCEPTIONAL STUDENT LEADERS
MANY WHO HAVE ACHIEVED SUCCESS
IN NATIONAL COMPETITIONS IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE FIELDS OF
STUDY AND WHO RECEIVED
EDUCATIONAL AWARDS AT THE STATE
AND NATIONAL LEVELS. THE
STUDENTS ARE JOINED TODAY BY
CAL POLY'S PRESIDENT DR JEFFREY
ARMSTRONG WHO SERVED AS
PRESIDENT AT CAL POLY SINCE
TWENTY ELEVEN AND UNDER HIS
GUIDANCE AND LEADERSHIP CAL
POLY CONTINUES TO SHINE AS ONE
OF THE GEMS OF THE CSU SYSTEM
HE'S JOINED TODAY BY HIS WIFE
SHARON MEMBERS PLEASE JOIN ME
IN WELCOMING PRESIDENT MISTER
ARMSTRONG IN THIS OUTSTANDING
GROUP OF STUDENTS. ON BEHALF OF
THE ENTIRE STATE SENATE. GO
MUSTANGS WE'RE GRATEFUL THAT
YOU'RE HERE TODAY. WE'RE GONNA
GATHER FOR AN OFFICIAL SENATE
PHOTOGRAPH. WE HAVE SEVERAL
STAFF ALUMNI WHO ARE PROUD OF
WOULD BE CUT FROM CAL POLY.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
WE'RE GONNA TAKE A QUICK PIES
ALLOW SENATORS TO BE ABLE TO
GREET OUR HONOR GAS ON THE
FLOOR AND WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK
WITH YOU.
BASINGER IN THE
SENATE WE LIKE TO BE TO MOVE
FORWARD WITH IN OUR FILE HERE
TODAY MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED. WE'RE
NOW MOVING FORWARD WITH MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS A NOTICES. ANY
INDIVIDUALS WOULD LIKE TO BE A
PRESENT UNDER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICE. HEARING
SEEN NON MONOGAMY MOVING FOR
THE CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY
FILE WE HAVE ONE ITEM. ITEM
FIFTEEN CENTER DOT IS PREPARED
TO PRESENT MISTER SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE READ. SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR DODD. RELATIVE TO
PROBLEM GAMBLING AWARENESS
MONTH. MEMBERS WE CAN HAVE YOUR
ATTENTION PLEASE CENTER DOT THE
FLOOR IS YOURS BOB MISTER
PRESIDENT MEMBERS- AS CHAIR OF
THE SENATE GEO COMMITTEE I AM
PROUD TO PRESENTS STATE SENATE
RESOLUTION SEVENTY EIGHT WHICH
RECOGNIZES MARCH OF TWENTY
TWENTY AS PROBLEM GAMBLING
AWARENESS MONTH IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. ALTHOUGH MOST
PEOPLE ARE ABLE TO GAMBLE
RESPONSIBLY FOR SOME IT BECOMES
A DEVASTATING ADDICTION THAT
AFFECTS NOT ONLY INDIVIDUAL BUT
THEIR LOVED ONES AS WELL.
FORTUNATELY GAMBLING ADDICTION
IS TREATABLE THAT IS WHY DURING
THE MONTH OF MARCH
ORGANIZATIONS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE COME TOGETHER TO EDUCATE
THE PUBLIC AND HEALTH CARE
PROFESSIONALS ABOUT THE WARNING
SIGNS A PROBLEM GAMING. THIS
RESOLUTION MORE WE RAISE
AWARENESS ABOUT THE HELP THAT
IS AVAILABLE BOTH LOCALLY AND
NATIONALLY FOR PROBLEM GAMBLERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. I WANT TO
THANK ALL SIXTY MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE GEO COMMITTEE FOR
OFFERING THIS RESOLUTION WITH
ME I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE. MEMBERS IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. CENTER PAN FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT SENATORS I TO RISE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THIS RESOLUTION
WHY THANK MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
MY NAPA FOR BRING THIS FORD. AS
VICE CHAIR OF THE P. I.
LEGISLATIVE CAUCUS. GAMBLING IS
A BIG CHALLENGE IN THE P. I.
COMMUNITY WE DON'T QUITE HAVE
THE SOCIAL STIGMA OUR CULTURAL
STIGMA AGAINST GAMBLING.
HOWEVER THIS DOES LEAD TO
CHALLENGES WHEN PEOPLE DO I GET
INTO THE TRAP OF- PROBLEM
GAMBLING OFTENTIMES OUR
COMMUNITIES ARE TARGETED. BY
ESTABLISHMENTS THAT ONE PROMOTE
GAMBLING BECAUSE OF. THE LACK
OF THE- LACK OF A CULTURE
STIGMA AGAINST GAMBLING SO WE
NEED TO ENSURE THAT. THERE'S
BOTH RECOGNITION AWARENESS OF-
PROBLEM GAMBLING AS WELL AS THE
AVAILABILITY OF HELP FOR
FAMILIES THERE STRUGGLING AND
FOR PEOPLE ARE STRUGGLING WITH
THIS. I OUT URGE AN AYE VOTE ON
THIS RESOLUTION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SIR PAN SENATORS IS
THERE NEED ANY ADDITIONAL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR. IN CINEMAS SECTOR
CAN PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN
HI ARCHULETA AYE ATKINS AYE
BATES HI BILL HI BOARD THIS.
AND FOR HI CAMBIADO BY SAYING.
THE ALLEY BY DONT HI THERE ALSO
ARE AYE GALGIANI BY GLAZER.
GONZALEZ FIVE GROVE HERTZBERG
BYE BYE HILL BY WES SO TADO HI
JACKSON HI JONES LEYVA. HI
MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL. MONNING HI
MORE LOCK. MORALE HI NIELSEN.
HI PAN BY PORTANTINO. ROTH HI
RUBIO. OUR EYES SKINNER. STERN
HI I'M BURKE. HI WHY CAL SKI.
WIENER HI WILK HI. THIS IS A
TRICKY PLEASE MOVE THE CALL.
MEMBERS. WE'RE NOW MOVING
FORWARD TO. MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS WERE GONNA JUMP
BACK TO THAT THIS IS NOW TIME
TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE BODY
IN. YOUR JOURNEY MEMORIES.
SENATOR LETTER YOU PREPARED TO
BE ABLE TO PRISON CENTER JULY
TO THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT. MY FELLOW
SENATORS I DRESS YOU TODAY WITH
THE- SAD SAD HEART. MOST OF US
WHO HAVE FRIENDS THAT WE'VE
GROWN UP WITH AND SOME HAVE
BECOME SISTERS MORE SO THAN
YOUR OWN SISTERS BROTHERS HAVE
BECOME BROTHERS AT EVEN MORE
SHOW THAT YOU HAVE HAVE HAD IN
YOUR LIVES. I LOST A BROTHER.
AND SOME OF YOU MAY KNOW I SURE
WITH A MINOR BILL POLICE
DEPARTMENT. IN ONE OF MY
PATNERS THAT I SHARED WITH FOR
TEN YEARS. THAT WE- SHARED OUR
FAMILIES TOGETHER OUR
FRIENDSHIPS TOGETHER. I WAS GOD
FATHER TO HIS SON. AND WE JUST
GREW CLOSER AND CLOSER AS THE
YEARS WENT BY HE HAD MY BACK I
HAD IS. AND STORIES MEMORIES I
HAVE WILL LAST FOREVER. BUT HIS
NAME IS TONY GARCIA. AND I
WOULD DETERMINE EVERYBODY TO
TEASE HIM AS THAT TONY IT WAS
ONLY WITHIN. ONLY GARCIA PROUD
VETERAN MARINE BUT I WANT TO
SHARE A LITTLE BIT ABOUT HIS
HISTORY BORN IN NINETEEN FORTY
NINE MARCH THIRD NINETEEN FORTY
NINE. AND IN THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT WHEN WE LOSE ONE WE
CALL THAT END OF WATCH WELL
ONLY HAD HIS END OF WATCH NOT
TOO LONG AGO ON FEBRUARY TWENTY
FIFTH AND- I WAS ABLE TO VISIT
WITH HIM AT THE HOSPITAL I WAS
ABLE TO VISIT WITH HIM ON HIS
VERY LAST THEY WERE VERY FIRST
DAY AT HOME BEFORE HE PASSED
AWAY IN HIS OWN HOME. AND I WAS
ACTUALLY WHEN A LOT OF US WERE
HAVING FUN WATCHING THE SUPER
BOWL I WAS THERE AT THE
HOSPITAL AT THE BEDSIDE JOEY
AND I WATCH THE GAME TOGETHER.
AND I WOULD POKE OF EVERY SO
OFTEN TO TRY TO KEEP HIM AWAKE.
TRYING TO GET HIM TO SMILE
AFTER RE AFTER THIS TERRIBLE
TERRIBLE STROKE THAT HE HAD.
AND THE WHEN I FIRST WENT TO
SEE HIM THE FIRST TIME. HE
COULDN'T EAT. SO HIS WIFE SAID
HE'S NOT A- POKED AT A MAN I
SAID ONLY COME ON BUDDY YOU
GOTTA EAT SO I GRABBED A BANANA
AND I BUILD IT THAT'S IT HERE
EAT THAT. ANY REACHED A VERY
WEEKLY ANY TOOK A GOOD BYE. AND
THE SAID HERE HAVE SOME SOUP
WHO IS ABLE TO EAT A LITTLE BIT
BUT IT WAS NEVER ENOUGH AS THE
DAYS WENT ON HE WAS IN THE
HOSPITAL FOR A FEW WEEKS. THE
DAYS WENT ON HE GOT WEAKER AND
WEAKER AND HE LEAVES BEHIND
HIS- HIS FAMILY. HIS WIFE HAITI
GARCIA WHO IS ALSO A MEMBER THE
BARBELL POLICE DEPARTMENT THE
DETECTIVE AND OF COURSE WE
ALWAYS TEASE TONY ABOUT DON'T
GET A SHOOT OUT WITH YOUR WIFE
AT HOME BECAUSE SHE ALLOWED
SHOULD YOU AND- SO WE TEACH
ABOUT THEM BUT THEY WERE THE
GARCIA FAMILY THAT BOTH FOR THE
BADGE BOTH FOR THE GOT. THERE
TO PROTECT AND SERVE THE
COMMUNITIES. BUT LET ME GO ON
IF I MAY HE- HAD A HISTORY OF
EDUCATING ITS CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY LOVED THE TEACHES
CHILDREN ABOUT THE MILITARY IN
ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND A
COMMITMENT ABOUT GOD COUNTRY.
HE LOVED HIS NEIGHBORS AND DOGS
UP AND DOWN THE STREET DAHLE WE
USED TO LOVE THIS SIONE BECAUSE
HE WOULD ALWAYS. HAVE FOOD FOR
THE DOG HE WOULD KNOW AND DAVID
JUST A GREAT GUY A GREAT
NEIGHBOR ANY LOVE ITALY BUT
GOODIES ELEVEN OLD CARS AND- HE
WAS ALWAYS TALKING ABOUT IT IS
FORTY NINE CHEVROLET PICKUP
TRUCK. IT WAS NOT ABLE TO
FINISH RESTORING. AND TALK
ABOUT IT BUT MIX MIXTURE OF
THINGS THESE IS- MOTHER WAS
MEXICAN AMERICAN HIS FATHER WAS
GIVEN. AND SO HE HAD THAT. THAT
ABILITY TO LOVE THE LATINO
SPICE THE FOOD EVERYTHING ELSE
IS PROVIDE WITH THREE BROTHERS
AND WIFE AS I MENTIONED IT. IS
CHILDREN A BET JAN YOU NEED A
PHONY. CAM ADAMANT A STEP ON.
OF FOURTEEN GRANDCHILDREN FOUR
GREAT GRANDCHILDREN. BUT I'M
ALSO ESPECIALLY PROUD NOT ONLY
OF HIS FAMILY BUT HIM. WHAT
HE'S GIVEN US HIS MILITARY
SERVICE HE SHOULD THE UNITED
STATES MARINE CORPS FROM
NINETEEN SIXTY SEVEN TO SEVENTY
ONE BEEN HONORABLY DISCHARGED
THE RANK OF SERGEANT HE WENT ON
TO SERVE IN THE MARINE CORPS
RESERVES- IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
ONE. HE COULDN'T GET ENOUGH OF
WEAR THE UNIFORM SHE HADN'T
JOINED THE AIRFORCE RESERVE
FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY FOUR TO
SEVENTY FIVE. AND WHEN THEY
WOULDN'T LET HIM FLY IN
AIRPLANES HE GOT UPSET HE SAID
I'LL JOIN THE NAVY MAYBE
THEY'LL LET ME DRIVE A BOAT. SO
HE JOINED THE NAVY RESERVE FROM
NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX TO SEVENTY
SEVEN WELL THAT WAS ENOUGH HE
SAID WELL MAYBE THE ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD WILL LET ME
DRIVE A TANK SO WE DROVE. SO HE
JOINED THE ARMY NATIONAL GUARD
FROM NINETEEN EIGHTY TO EIGHTY
TWO. BUT HE DID SO MUCH HE LEAD
THIS GREAT COUNTRY AND HE WAS A
GREAT PARTNER WITH ME IN
MONTEBELLO PIEDADE. BUT HE- HE-
HE WENT ON TO SERVE A- THE
INGLEWOOD POLICE DEPARTMENT.
AND SENATOR YOUR CITY. AND
SERVED IN NINETEEN AT NINETEEN
SEVENTY ONE IN INGLEWOOD. AND
HIS SON. CAM IS NOW AN OFFICER
THERE IN INGLEWOOD FOLLOWING
HIS FOOTSTEPS. HE WAS A MEMBER
OF A UNION LOCAL TWO FIFTY
HEATING VENTILATION AND AIR
CONDITIONING HE WAS IN THAT
UNIT FOR FORTY TWO YEARS. AND
HE GRADUATED FROM THAT RIHANNA
POLICE ACADEMY IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE AND SHARED WITH
BARBELL POLICE FROM NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE TO NINETY SEVEN. AND
I JUST WANT A IF I MAY JUST A
SHORT NOTE FROM HIS DAUGHTER.
THAT SHE SAID MADE THAT. SHE
HAD WRITTEN A FEW LINES THAT I
THINK WE ALL CAN RELATE TO
THIS. HE CALLED HIM PAPA. HELLO
I MISS YOU. I WANT ONE MORE
WALK WITH YOU ONE MORE CHAT ONE
MORE HUG A KISS FROM MY PAPA MY
HEART CHAU ACHE FROM LOSING YOU
AND MY BROTHER YES ONLY LOST
HIS OLDEST SON PHONY JUNIOR SO
SHE WRITES I MISS MY OWN THESE.
I DON'T THINK I COULD EVER
UNDERSTAND WHY YOU BOTH HAD TO
LEAVE SO SOON. THANK YOU FOR
BEING SUCH A GREAT DAD. MADE
HIS CHILDREN FEEL LIKE THEY CAN
DO ANYTHING AND JUST ANYTHING
THEY WANTED THEY COULD ACHIEVE.
YOU DIDN'T BELIEVE IN EXCUSES
YOU TAUGHT US ALL THINGS THAT
ACCOMPLISHMENTS
THEMSELVES YOU PHAM PRIDE IN
WORKING HARD AND NEVER LETTING.
ANYTHING OR ANYONE GET IN YOUR
WAY. YOUR QUEST FOR KNOWLEDGE
WITH A GREAT GIFT YOU SIMPLY
LOVE TO LEARN. AND I ALWAYS ASK
THAT EVERYONE THAT IF YOU
WANTED TO KNOW SOMETHING JUST
ASK MY DAD. YOUR SERVICE TO OUR
COUNTRY. WAS AMAZING FOR
HONORABLE DISCHARGES. DAD WE'RE
GONNA MISS YOU I WILL FOREVER
LOVE BY PAPA. SO I WILL FOREVER
MISS MY BROTHER. BECAUSE
SOMETIMES YOUR BEST FRIEND WILL
BE CLOSER TO YOU THAN YOUR OWN
BROTHER EVEN YOUR OWN SISTER.
SO END OF WATCH JOHNNY. GOD
LOVE YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO MUCH MR SENATOR FOR THAT.
VERY PERSONAL BUT YOU'RE IN
MEMORY. IF YOU COULD PLEASE
BRING THE PAPERWORK UP IN
PLEASE ACCEPT OUR DEEPEST
CONDOLENCES. UNDER SADDAM
CENTER RUBIO WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON PRESIDENTE MEMBERS I
ALSO WANT TO ADJOURN ON BEHALF
OF THE MEMORY OF ANI GARCIA I
HE WAS MY CONSTITUENTS AND HE
RESIDED IN THE CITY OF COVINA
BUT MOST IMPORTANTLY I WANT TO
OFFER MY CONDOLENCES FOR THE
GREAT SENATOR OF PICO RIVERA. I
KNOW HE WAS YOUR LONG TIME
FRIEND AND- WE FEEL YOUR YOUR
HEART AT THIS MOMENT US SO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD I ALSO WANT TO SEND
THEIR CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY
HIS DAUGHTER AS YOU SHARED AW
AND WANT TO THANK HIM FOR HIS
SERVICE TO THIS COUNTRY. AND
THE POLICE DEPARTMENT SO I ALSO
ADD AN INJURED IN A MEMORY OF
THIS GREAT MAN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU SO MUCH CENTER RUBIO.
MEMBERS MAY I WOULD LIKE TO
BETTER RECOGNIZE SENATOR PAN
FOR NEXT ADJOURNMENT. I THANK
YOU- THE PRESIDENT- SENATORS
TODAY I RISE TO TURN MEMORY
PATRICK MALARKEY WHO PASSED
AWAY TUESDAY AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY EIGHT. HIS PASSING WAS A
GREAT LOSS FOR THE PEOPLE OF
SACRAMENTO HE WAS AN OUT TRULY
AN OUTSTANDING PUBLIC SERVANT
HE SERVED AS A MEMBER OF THE
TECHNO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
FROM NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE TO
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. AND
DOCTOR MALARKEY BROUGHT
ATTENTION TO A NUMBER OF
CRITICAL ISSUES LIKE
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND THE
AND HISTORIC PRESERVATION. PARK
MALARKEY HEADED A SUCCESSFUL
DENTAL PRACTICE. HE GAVE HIS
HEART TO THE POOREST AMONG US
HE WAS KNOWN FOR FIXING THE
TEETH OF POOR PEOPLE ACROSS
THIS HAPPENED NO COST. IS ALSO
THE OWNER OF THE POPULAR TAVERN
ON BROADWAY CALLED MALARKEY IS
PLACE WHERE PEOPLE GATHER TO
LISTEN TO MUSIC AND ENJOYED
ADULT BEVERAGES. I'M NOT SURE
THAT WENT WITH THE TEETH HIS
FRIENDS FAMILY AND THE SECOND-
COMMUNITY WILL ALWAYS REMEMBER
HIS INTELLECT HIS HUMOR AND HIS
INTEGRITY. AND WE WILL MISS HIM
GREATLY PLEASE JOIN JOIN ME IN
A JOURNEY IN MEMORY OF PATRICK
MALARKEY THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SO MUCH CENTER PAN IN PLEASE
SEND OUR DEEP CONDOLENCES TO
THE FAMILY. MEMBERS WOULD LIKE
TO TURN THE FLOOR OVER TO
SENATOR NIELSEN. THIS PRESIDENT
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE.
WE HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY HERE
AND I HAVE THIS PARTICULAR
PLEASURE. OF DOING THIS THE
GERMAN MEMORY WITH MY ESTEEMED
COLLEAGUE FROM THE ASSEMBLY KEN
COOLEY. HE JUST TO DE DURING
THE ASSEMBLY IN HONOR OF DOUG
HOLLAND. DOUG IS ONE OF OURS
WORKED MANY YEARS HERE FOR US.
FOR THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA.
ONE WHO REALLY KNEW THE
INSTITUTION. HE CAME FROM
MINNESOTA HE TRAVELED A LONG
WAYS. THE END UP HERE THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LEGISLATURE.
WE'RE VERY LUCKY THAT HE DID.
HE WAS A RIGHT RADAR OPERATOR
IN THE UNITED STATES AIRFORCE.
IT IS TIME IN DEFENSE OF OUR
LAND. HE ALSO THEN STARTED A
PRIVATE SECURITY COMPANY IS A
MAN OF MANY DIVERSE TALENTS. AN
ENTREPRENEUR OF. WHICH IS A
COURAGEOUS RISK TAKER ALL
THINGS DON'T WORK OUT BUT HIS
DEATH. BUT HE STILL DECIDED
THAT ONE TIME THAT HE WOULD
COME HERE AND SERVE. THE PEOPLE
IN THIS ESTEEMED INSTITUTION.
HE WAS THE CHIEF CONSULTANT IN
THE ASSEMBLY REPUBLICAN OFFICE
OF POLICY. FOR YEARS AND WHEN I
BRIEFLY SERVED IN THAT HOUSE I
HAD THE PLEASURE OF WORKING
WITH HIM. AGAIN THE HAD A OF A
SON WHO WAS LOST A GRANDSON
DESTINED. AND THAT'S A THAT'S A
TOUGH CHALLENGE FOR ANY OF US
HAVE GOT TO CONTEND WITH. HE
WAS A THE VOTER LEADER OF THE
CRIME VICTIMS MOVEMENT THAN
ADVOCATE. OF THOSE OFTEN
FORGOTTEN. AMERICANS AND
CALIFORNIANS. HE WORKED ON
LEGISLATION. IT WAS NAMED.
DUSTIN'S LAW. HONORING IS
RANSOM. HE. WORK WITHIN HIS
COMMUNITY TO SUPPORT COUNTLESS
COMMUNITY ACTIVITIES TO MAKE
THAT COMMUNITIES BETTER FOR ALL.
SO HE SERVED IN MANY WAYS. MANY
CAPACITIES AND DOUG HOLLAND
AFFECTED MANY LIVES. ONE OF THE
SPECIAL TRAITS HE HAD WAS HIS
INSTITUTIONAL KNOWLEDGE AND HOW
TO FIT THAT KNOWLEDGE TOGETHER
FOR THE CONSTRUCTIVE PURPOSES
OF THESE TIMES. A LOT OF PEOPLE
DO NOT WANT TO LOOK BACK THEY
LOOK AT THEIR OWN BILL TODAY
AND THAT'S THE FIRST THING I
EVER SAW AND IT'S THE BEST IDEA
THAT EVERYONE AS WELL MANY
THINGS WENT ON BEFORE. AND DOUG
COLLINS WOULD ALWAYS. QUIETLY
POLITELY REMIND US. OF THE
SUCCESSES AND THE FAILURES OF
FORMER ATTEMPTS. THAT IS A MARK.
OF A TRUE QUALITY CONSULTANT.
UNTIMELY HE PASSED AWAY
RECENTLY AND- IT MADE IT
THROUGH THE YEAR OF IT. WE HAVE
LOST IN. HIS LOVELY JANE IS
HERE WITH US TODAY. THEY WERE
MARRIED. MANY MANY YEARS. HE
WAS PRECEDED IN DEATH BY THE
BRANSON DUSTIN WITH FOR WHICH
AT DUSTIN'S LAW WAS NAMED. AND
HE HAS MANY OTHER. CHILDREN AND
GRAND CHILDREN. ONE OF HIS
DAUGHTERS IN LAW IS HOLDING IN
THE BACK. HIS YOUNGEST. AND
WHAT A BLESSING TO HAVE THAT
YOUNG MAN HERE. TO BE
RECOGNIZED AND ACKNOWLEDGED IN
THE STATE SENATE AND SOME DAY I
KNOW THE FAMILY WILL BRING THAT
TO HIS ATTENTION. TOUGH
PRECIOUS. IN A CAN KNOW HOW
WERE HIS GRANDFATHER SO NOBLY
SERVED THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. LATE IN
GENTLEMAN DOUG COLLINS. WAS
JUST A GOOD MAN. WITH A GOOD
HEART. A CARING HEART AND A
DEDICATED LIFE TO IMPROVING THE
LIVES OF OTHERS VERY
PARTICULARLY IS VERY OWN FAMILY.
WE KNOW THAT GOD HAS A HOME IN
HEAVEN FOR HIM AND HIS HOUSE OF
MANY MANSIONS. THEY DUG BE
COMFORTED THERE AND HIS FAMILY%
BE COMFORTED HERE. AND MAY OUR
PRAYERS. LIFT THEM UP. AS A
GRIEVOUS PASSING. DOUG COLLINS.
A TRUE CALIFORNIAN ONE OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S BEST. THANK YOU
CENTER NIELSEN INTO THE HALL
AND FAMILY. WE ARE SO SORRY FOR
YOUR LOSS WE'RE GRATEFUL YOU'RE
HERE WITH US TODAY IN THANK YOU
SIR NIELSEN FOR ADVANCING
MANAGER NEW MEMORY. MEMBERS WE
NOW WOULD LIKE TO BE A TO GO
BACK TO ANNOUNCEMENTS. CENTER
LEYVA THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU MISTER PRESIDENT GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS I JUST WANTED
TO POINT OUT IS THIS IS THE
BEGINNING OF WOMEN'S HISTORY
MONTH AND YOU EACH HAVE A
CALENDAR ON YOUR DESK YOU CAN
ORDER THESE FROM SENATE RIVER
GRAPHICS AND WHERE IT HAS MY
NAME YOU MAY HAVE THEM PUT YOUR
NAME PEOPLE LOVE THEM IN THE
DISTRICT EVERY DAY HAS FUN
FACTS SO TODAY MARCH SECOND.
ONE OF THE FUN FACTS IS ABOUT
ANNA SAILOR WHO SPONSORED THE
BILL THE INDEED THE DEATH
PENALTY FOR THOSE UNDER
EIGHTEEN SO WOMEN HAVE BEEN
DOING GOOD WORK FOR A VERY LONG
TIME I WOULD HIGHLY ENCOURAGE
THAT YOU ORDER SOME OF THESE
AND TAKE THEM TO YOUR DISTRICT
THEY'RE FUN TO GIVE OUT AND
EVENTS AND PEOPLE LIKE THEM
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER LEYVA
MEMBERS WE DO HAVE A RESOLUTION
THAT IS CURRENTLY ON CALL WE'D
LIKE TO BE A LIFT THE CALLS
MISTER SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
PORCHES CHIANG GLAZER ROSE
WESTELL JONES MITCHELL MORE
LOCK PORTANTINO SKINNER WHY CAO
SKI HI HI. EYES TWENTY NINE
KNOWS ZERO THE RESOLUTION IS
ADOPTED. IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS THAT IS IN GERMAN
CENTER ATKINS THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT-
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU- I WILL
SEE YOU ON THURSDAY MARCH FIFTH
TWENTY TWENTY- AT NINE THIRTY I
WANNA MAKE SURE YOU HEAR NINE
THIRTY IT'S A LITTLE DIFFERENT
THAN. A REGULAR THURSDAY SO WE
WILL SEE YOU AT NINE THIRTY
THANK YOU MISTER PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU MAYOR PRO TEM LAZY
CHEN THE SENATE THE SENATE WILL
BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE THIRTY
PM AT WHICH TIME THE GERMAN
MOTION WILL BE MADE WE'RE GONNA
RECONVENE THURSDAY AT NINE
THIRTY ONCE AGAIN. NINE THIRTY
AM ON THURSDAY GET OUT TO VOTE
TOMORROW STARTING AT SEVEN AM.